[Music]
look how blue that water is
[Music]
all right guys you're gonna die you will
go with me and this divers you have
buddies so your buddies together how
long are you together already together
yeah together does it look like that I
don't know I see a kiss there so I don't
know oh those are lips
[Music]
I still technically might be married and
he's mad about that but here he is with
a whole permanent tattoo
I feel like it's almost a little
hypocritical of him he's curious about
why I haven't done things but why
haven't you removed that
all right let's get ready dumbled down
look straight forward one big step
all right
[Music]
[Music]
we're 23 feet under the surface
there are so many schools of fish I see
a stingray
it's absolutely breathtaking it's so
beautiful like I'm just ecstatic I live
for moments like this
this date is going really well
but I've never really
dated
in the sense of like looking for a
partner
dating intentionally for a future
partner comes with pain sadness
rejection
I'm scared of the risks but doesn't mean
I don't want them
[Music]
but the guy was good
yeah he was really good very nice
I'm glad to survived survived yeah all
right so question I have a question what
um whose lips are on you what
um
okay it was an ex-girlfriend and you
haven't decided to cover it up because
listen this is a tattoo okay girl had
beautiful lips to me tattoos are more
permanent than papers why because that
paper that paper literally like inside
and I'm divorced but you still have a
tattoo on you
yeah
papers those are definite you cannot
marry another person until it's
finalized that's the thing a tattoo is
done
[Music]